I found this microwave in my neighbors garbage can. So I took it home, and turned into an
AC stick welder. In this project, we'll be
testing out this contraption to see if it
actually works. Because if it does, we'll
have the metal welding power to make a puzzle
for entertaining guests, or build improvised
weapons for a zombie apocalypse.
I just modified these microwave oven transformers
to weld metal, and made a little container
for it all to fit into. This arc welder is
finished and ready for testing, so to do that
I got some pieces of scrap metal from a welding
shop down the road. I switched out the blade
on my chop-saw with this cutting wheel and
I'm cutting these bits of steel into smaller
pieces. The sparks are pretty hot and fly
everywhere, so it's important to wear protection
and keep them away from anything flammable.
Ok, our pieces are cut and resting on this
larger piece of metal. This is gonna act
as a base plate for the ground clip to connect
to. I've got a 6013 welding rod that gets
clipped into the stinger, and the amperage
is controlled with this device I call the
ScariAc. Look for how to build this in another
video. The amps are adjusted to work with
these 1/16" cellulose coated rods, and with
2 of our pieces butted up next to each other,
it's time to see if we can strike an arc.
They say it's kind of like striking a match,
and there we go. These welding rods are consumable,
meaning they get used up in the weld. You
can actually see where the end of the rod
turns to molten metal and pools into the joint.
To give this a little more strength,
let's flip it over and do the same thing to
the top side. The UV radiation from stick
welding is enough to give you a pretty bad
sun burn, so if you try it, make sure you're
protected from head to toe. Alright, the weld
has cooled, so now we can knock off the layer
of slag that's formed on top, then clean it
up with a wire brush. Now it looks good to
me, but I've never really welded before so
I'm not sure how to tell if the weld is good
or not, so let's break it. The piece gets
clamped in a bench vise and these channel
lock pliers should give us the leverage we
need. I'm actually expecting this will snap
in the middle … but it didn't. I welded
another piece and tried bending it back and
forth multiple times to snap the weld, but
the joint never broke. Just for fun and a
bit more practice, let's weld all the scrap
pieces together. I've also got these framing
nails we can tack on in random places, and
a link of galvanized chain we can weld to
the end. Well, I think it's safe to say this
welder is working. And I've got my first piece
of metal art to prove it. It's a little rough,
and probably not the kind of decor I'd want
to put on display, but in a weird way I kind
of like it. Now I'm amazed that even with
all this welding, the transformer coils are
only slightly warm to the touch. I tried welding
some larger 3/32 rods and that was a different
story. They work alright, but the welder heats
up fast. To cool it down, I have a fan that
was salvaged from one of the microwaves, and
it slides right up to the vent hole on the
left. When it's turned on, air flows over
the transformer coils, and exhausts out the
other side. In the case of extreme overheating,
the whole top lifts right off for maximum
ventilation. This welds metal pretty good
in my opinion, but I took it to another welder
to get his thoughts on how it worked. He tried
some welds on pieces of his own scrap steel,
and seemed pretty impressed with the results.
He said the weld penetrated the metal completely,
and probably wouldn't break. So we tried some
more destructive testing to break the weld,
but even with good leverage and quite a bit
of force, the weld held strong and the metal
broke first. To finish this project up, let's
try making something a little more useful.
This time I've got a horseshoe and some chain,
and I'm welding the links in-line with the
tips of the shoe. This 2" steel ring goes
over both of the chains, and the remaining
links are welded onto another shoe. We can
clean up the welds in the usual way, and look
at that. We've got a horseshoe puzzle ready
for entertaining. The challenge is to get
the ring off, which seems impossible because
the ring is way too small. But it can be done,
and my wife just proved it. Why don't you
make your own and see if you can figure out
how it's done? Well there's a MOT stick welder
that works, and my first few experiences with
the world of welding. If you liked this project,
perhaps you'll like some of my others. Check
them out at www.thekingofrandom.com